coming up in Parliament's plenary
session in Strasbourg the fight against
animal disease including diseases
contractible by humans the plight of
women refugees and asylum seekers and a
terrifying echo from childhoods past eat
your vegetables and drink your milk
it'll make you fit and healthy the peril
of animal diseases like swine fever and
asian flu has swept the headlines in
recent years on monday mep s will debate
a law which clusters almost 40 items of
legislation designed to point up the
obligations of farmers traders vets and
pet owners to avoid the spread of
disease the new legislation will be
voted on on Tuesday
in the maelstrom of issues surrounding
the refugee crisis scant attention goes
to women many are fleeing rape forced
marriage or genital mutilation on their
journey they face assault on Tuesday
after hearing from the UN High
Commissioner for Refugees Filippo grandi
MEP s will vote on proposals recognising
the unique situation for women including
the need for gender segregated
facilities and health and child care
services not by chance is it
International Women's Day
em eps are not happy with the way the
world's tobacco giants are tackling
cigarette smuggling nor with the
european commission's recent
anti-counterfeiting deals with them mep
s want new tracking systems in place
they'll be voting on a resolution on
better scrutiny tools on wednesday and
now in grief that some other key events
the efficiency of europe's ports and
their diverse costs and operating
methods are to be scrutinized on tuesday
during the vote on market access to
ports it's designed to ensure fair and
transparent fee setting and with it
boost trade
MEP s will vote on a draft deal between
the EU s main institutions to improve
lawmaking it's part of the younger
Commission's pledge to do less better
improving the planning quality and
transparency of lawmaking and public
understanding of it all on Thursday mvps
will debate the reform efforts of
Montenegro and the former yugoslav
republic of macedonia pointing to
progress by both towards EU membership
they'll also debate the deteriorating
human rights and rule of law in Eritrea
where many of the refugees recently
arriving in Europe come from the outcome
of the special EU summit on migration
will be debated on Tuesday the spring
meeting of EU government leaders will
also be debated last month it was all
about the deal with the UK this month
its new proposals on migration and
eurozone governance the same day
there'll be a debate with a prime
minister of Sweden Stefan LOVEFiLM
drink your milk enjoy your fruit eat
your greens parental orders that surely
strike dread in the minds of chips and
chocolate loving children but their
consumption of fruit milk and vegetables
continues to fall across Europe around
20 million or overweight adolescents eat
only thirty to fifty percent of the
recommended daily intake em EPS will
debate merging the EU schools milk and
vegetable schemes lifting the budget by
twenty million euros to 250 million no
excuses eat up that's it for a packed
plenary week which you can follow on
your car TV enjoy the beach